The answer is, given the assumptions here, P must not be prime.
And the reason for that is P is greater than Pn.
And we said this set includes all prime numbers--
that's the assumption we started with for this proof,
and this number's the product of many numbers--
all of these are positive, adding 1 to it.
So the value of P must be greater that P sub N
and that means, according to our assumption about the limited set of all primes,
P must not be prime.
So since P is not a prime, that means it must be a composite--
which means it must be the product of some prime number and some other integer.
So that means we can write P as some prime,
and we've said all the primes are in this set,
so it's something selected from that set,
multiplied by some other number--we don't know what Q is
other than it must be an integer.
So now we have P, which we computed as the product of all these primes plus 1
which is equal to some prime from that set times Q.